the me to movement I think we can all
agree has brought to light a lot of
offensive behavior by a lot of men and
rightfully so and has been to the great
good and many people think that your
case it made them feel uneasy and there
was some questions and uneasiness about
your particular situation and how it was
resolved as you know last month The New
Yorker came out with a very exhaustive
piece that I and there's a lot of
support for you in this piece in The New
Yorker piece it says that seven of your
colleagues who did not support you at
the moment when you had to resign now
say they regret it and since then I
believe in eighth colleague has come out
and said I also regret not supporting al
is this article and is it feeling to you
like there's a bit of a sea change it's
just a watershed moment for you or
getting this support is that important
to you I think there's a lot of division
on this issue yeah it was very
gratifying to have seven colleagues who
had all apologised to me but to be
public in order to get a u.s. senator to
publicly admit you know he or she made a
mistake that's real that's that's hard
and to get neat you know that's unusual
yeah and so they just basically all said
that I deserve due process and I believe
I did too okay well now that's that's
the important point for a lot of people
in your situation is that you resigned
you step down and a lot of people feel
if you were confident in your case why
resign why step down what is it that you
had to go through that led you to say
nope I've got to go well I think those
eight colleagues have apologized because
they know the untenable position I was
put in why tell explain to people
what that position was at that moment
when you felt I've worked hard to become
a u.s. senator and I believe in my case
I why would you not go through the
process I don't want to name any names
but you know it the the my committee
work would be at risk
I mean basically losing that my staff
would be isolated and I just couldn't
serve the people of Minnesota but it
really it you know it really needed to
have a process but I I just couldn't
couldn't stay either it was a it was an
awful
there was no good choices there's no
good choices and you felt I'm and there
was a lot of pressure on you just
stepped down a tremendous amount of
pressure and I I don't think I had any
other choice you've had it's been a year
and a half and you've had a lot of time
to reflect have you is there anything
you've learned in the time that you've
been thinking about that came from this
situation well yeah you know when this
first happened if you had asked me have
you ever made a woman feel uncomfortable
by the way you you put your arm around
her or touched her or something like
that I would have said no and after all
these allegations came in I thought well
it must be doing something wrong so
right now you know ever since I've been
a lot more mindful in my interactions
with with pretty much everyone right
yeah so it has you you had time to
reflect and say okay I need to I mean
when you read this article there are and
all of your friends are coming
forward and showing you a great deal of
support and a lot of people that you
know is showing you a great day people
know me know that I'm not that guy that
that guy that that 36 of my colleagues
demanded that I go right and put on the
pressure came on me in no uncertain
terms that I had to go